this is an extremely titillating story
Venice california's neighborhood council
wants women to be treated to the same
freedom as men when it comes to going
topless along the SoCal City shoreline
councilmember Melissa diner presented a
free the nipple bill saying this is a
serious equality issue and I'm not going
to shy away from it diners bill passed
the council 12 to 2 now members will be
asking for Venice Beach to be exempt
from restrictions that require women to
cover their breasts in public spaces the
council said Venice Beach was founded
and designed around the European culture
Venice Italy topless sunbathing is
commonplace throughout Europe much of
the rest of the world in many places
within the United States
all right so technically right now we
are in Venice are we not we are on
Venice Boulevard in Venice all right so
oh wait I got it you saw where we were
going all you - I know you like to take
it as a feminist I say let the titties
go yeah free the breasts free the
nipples ok Europe they have no problem
with breasts they're doing this on
beaches people are not accosting people
people are not being sexually attacked
or assaulted why are we so afraid of the
breasts well I actually read that the
council member that put this a bill
forward I guess it Isabelle said that
she wants us to be more like Europeans
but like ok fine show your boobies but
do we have to want to do everything like
you're Emile's like I don't want to sit
on a bidet eating Nutella at 4:00 in the
morning at a rave in Barcelona you know
what it means actually doesn't sound
terrible I don't know that sounds very
freeing but I think that's totally fine
let's show some nipples but you know
there was a video that was going viral
on Facebook of this bodacious beautiful
woman and chin gorgeous boobs in a crop
top that was barely below her nipples
and she was running like full-on down
the beach and some ocean and the only
thing I thought is that just looks so
painful you know what I mean that's a
woman it's not good for the back right
yeah it just is it is her cross to bear
so to speak yeah a woman I tend to think
you're okay with us becoming a little
more European oh yeah well I mean our
art
oceans around sex sexuality human
anatomy just they're ridiculous they're
you know they're they're Puritan
Christian driven things that most people
don't really care about and just I do
think it's tragic though that there are
a tiny little handful of tiny little
places in America where you can swim
naked in the ocean I mean that seems it
seems very very wrong it seems like to
just take your clothes off sitting us on
wander into the into the water it's kind
of a basic fundamental human human
animal reality man on earth scenario
yeah it's crazy
yeah do you think we're ever raisi that
it's so dead expect so restrict that it
has to be litigated and yeah it's good
oxidizers it's pathetic it's pathetic do
you think it's weird that America we
have such in you know this like constant
dichotomy between like well am I wrong
and then also the man-woman thing but
like to me this is all I'm totally with
you on that like it's your body if we
could gut not be so hung up on this
stuff then everyone could do what they
want and we wouldn't i think we'd end up
having less sexual crime or whatever
they fear is gonna happen because of
this i think we would have less of if we
get over the hangers well we've I mean I
know the body is not sexual be nude is
not sexualizing yeah you know that how
that's been conflated is a little tragic
- yeah until like the 1900s even a man
showing his nipples was against the law
well that that would be that would be
you although as I get older and didn't
flap your I I I kind of want to get one
of those one-piece suits one of those I
wish those who come back one of the
little tiny why are you big mustache
yeah no one's in Calgary in the hot
spring oh you did it was weird
comfortable no it did like just be big
in kind of
now you know what a sports bras like and
actually was a rental which like that's
weird that changes things good man to
that now they just wear t-shirts when
men go to the beach are those t-shirts
and like come on dude you're not
tricking anyone we know what's up we
know whatever anyways do you fear the
breasts would it be okay if women went
topless in Venice or would the wrath of
God come down and destroy us let us know
your thoughts in the comments right now